you got the show on no jumper
mad lately about to do 30 episodes or
just
we just hit so congrats on that i
appreciate that once a week
yeah every monday so every monday it's
you gabe see i forget the young lady's
name
gina gina views um how did that come
come to be
um so adam i know i've been known adam
for like three years
now um no probably four yeah four since
like 2017 like
around the time we're like shoreline
right was blowing up greedo all them
we just kept running into each other and
um
i had them on my podcast once and then
after that i would just like send them
emails of like
dope videos that i thought were dope and
then people like cool i'm gonna put this
on the no jumper youtube and
i just kept like a constant line of
communication with him for a while
and um you know like we'd run into each
other certain places i'd
i think he started to grow like more of
a respect for me because a lot of places
he would be i would be
you know what i'm saying like i was
enrolling out of miami he was enrolling
on miami
i was enrolling out in new york he was
there any concert backstage did he see
me i was just hustling you know what i
mean so like
um we just grew like a cool relationship
and then at the beginning of 2020
he like said he wanted to meet went to
his office and then he was like yeah i
want you to do like a podcast or
something
he's like not rose crane's radio i want
you to do something different and i was
like all right cool
and then like covet happened and then so
like everything just kind of pushed back
and all that stuff and then he hit me
again
in like august i want to say august or
september and was like hey
you know did you want to do that podcast
still like we're about to you know
have some more podcasts on here and i
was like [ __ ] yeah
and i said give me like three four days
to come up with like a concept
and a name and everything and so came up
with the name
recruited my co-host you know i had gina
i had gabe
and then we did like a photo shoot and i
shot everything to him in like three
four days he was like oh [ __ ]
it was like ready to go yeah he's like
damn you guys are ready to go i'm like
yeah we're [ __ ] ready to go
what's um because you were doing the
rosecrans radio what is like the
like something that you learned doing
because it's kind of a different type of
thing so like yeah
you know with any with anything you get
better as time goes but what's something
you had to kind of like
learn from making the switch and doing
mad lately
um it's like streamed on youtube so
people commenting yeah
i mean yeah it's just a way different
platform so i approach it differently
like
rosecrans radio was just like me
interviewing artists or
talking you know not too deeply i wasn't
really
trying to like make people laugh
anything too much like it was just kind
of like a
i wanted to i had like a more serious
tone on there i guess you could say
but then i'm like okay we're going no
jumper like they have a certain audience
yeah you guys are definitely shooting
the [ __ ] now you know what i'm saying so
i'm like
we have to turn it up to a certain
extent or people are going to call us
boring or whatever and
the funny thing is that like the way i
am on mad lately like
that's really the real that's you yeah
you know what i'm saying when i'm out
with my homies and stuff like that so
i'm like [ __ ] it i'm gonna just put
myself on display and like
it like ruins my life but it like makes
it way better at the same time because
i'm a little too honest sometimes